thank you Alex again following up on a
team
not much discrete in this talk but I'll
try to put in as much as I can all right
so the motivation we're going to look at
a large class of linear programs the
time this specific property that the
matrices the constraint matrix a and B
are non-negative and I mean entry wise
no negative okay so this is the kind of
LP we look at and you think about it
this is somehow a natural class if you
look at like algorithm stats book and
look at the first examples that awful
piece we show to students they must have
time to be on this kind because in using
this kind of constraints you can express
things like budgets and costs and
requirements so packing and covering
constraints so this is a natural class
of linear programs discrete optimization
connection you can solve bipartite
matching within this family of
constraints and actually turns out that
some of the algorithms I'll be talking
about today achieve the best-known
running times for approximating a
maximum weight matching in a bipartite
graph without ever exploiting the
matching structure only looking the fact
that this matrix is non-negative so
that's interesting there are more
applications that maybe I'll mention at
the end sometimes the techniques that go
behind solving algorithms for this
problem are broader and they apply in
different scenarios and I'll talk about
that at the end and I should mention
that my content-wise my biggest slide is
the open problem slide so there's a lot
that I personally didn't understand
about these methods
okay so let's start with some basic
transformations you can think you can
immediately see that we can assume that
this right hand sides are positive
because if the matrices are positive and
the variables are positive there is no
way that this left hand side can be
negative so the right hand side should
be positive otherwise the problem the
constraint can be either trivial to
satisfy or trivial infeasible so again
be positive or non-negative and then we
we can scale everything up or down we
can scape the constraints up or down to
make our linear program look like this
I'm gonna call this the covering
constraints and the packing constraints
for obvious reasons here you are trying
to reach a constraint is trying to say
that an inner product between C and X is
at least something and you're between P
and X is at most something so this is
kind of my canonical form that I want to
think about for this non-negative linear
programs and what are we trying to do so
there are a lot of different models and
different questions we look at when we
try to design folders for this we are
mostly interested in approximate solvers
so imagine that we are really looking at
large-scale data so actually people at
Google and Amazon and I've talked to
quite a bit about implementing some of
this stuff sweet we are not going to try
and cedar point methods we are happy
with a poly one over epsilon dependence
our approximation parameter and we are
interested in in values models of
computation so we derive results for
simple sequential model of computation
parallel models and even distributed
models which are kind of more important
in practice and it's kind of very
interesting that the specific techniques
tailored to these non-negative linear
programs that are do not generalize to
generally linear programs are robust
enough that they give us interesting
algorithms in all these models
and so first let me is a kind of a
technical detail that's very important
like what do I mean when I say action
approximation I mean really a plus or
minus epsilon here in the scaled version
which you should really think about as a
multiplicative approximation in the
original formulation okay so if you want
to think in a scale-free way you want to
make sure that you find an X you could
scale the axes up or down arbitrarily
here you want to make sure that this
kind of relation so this is important
because a lot of the standard machinery
will give you additive approximations
and those happen to be the same when I
apply to this formulation
they're kind of incomparable when
applied to other formulations I argue
that for this context and typically
approximation is something that makes
sense okay so turns out that this is
even lots of the batter inside an
algorithms we have actually worked for
even more restricted classes which are
just pure packing and pure covering
problems so these are the name suggest
your packing is when we just have
packing constraints no covering
constraints but the objective is
maximization you can really think of
these as packing constraints plus one
covering constraints one therapeutics is
at least some gamma okay and it's the
same thing you have a like one packing
constraint and a lot of covering
constraints
so turns out that solving these guys is
actually much easier at least other
level we understand things because it's
not time to check that the dual of a
pack if a pure packing problem is a
covering problem and vice versa that
doesn't apply in general to a general
non non negative linear program which is
also called the mixed packing and
covering does not have this kind of
duality properties it's not closed and
all right so why why do I bring this
class up so what's special about this
class is that we have we can get this
multiplicative approximation in a way
that's much more efficient than we can
for generic linear programs do something
special about is no negative constraint
structure that allows us fast algorithms
a generic is a program you can really
think about non smooth convex
optimization problem and for non smooth
convex optimization problem if you
follow kind of classical theory of first
order methods the running time of your
algorithm will depend on something which
called the Lipschitz parameter of your
objective often denoted by a row in the
case of linear programs this is often
called the wit affiliate program that
you can really think about it as the
largest entry appearing in any of the
constraint matrices so the largest
number inside your constraint that's
kind of it that's a measure of no
smoothness because it says that if you
change your input by a little bit one of
the constraints will be affected by
something by a little bit Delta one of
this constraint will be affected by an
amount which is Delta times Rho so if a
small change in Delta can cause a huge
change like Delta times through the
Dodgers there is the more non smooth the
problem is
okay so usually if you follow again
classical first order method that is not
much you can do to get rid of these row
dependence so the most trivial thing
gives you a row squared over epsilon
square number of gradient computations
and yeah when I say get you the
computation you should always think
about some simple matrix vector
multiplication it's a nice trick by
plotting mass and tarnish that achieves
what's called a wit reduction so they
can get ro you looking at the multiple
temporal summation just with Rho over
epsilon square and then if you go it's
gonna willing to use next refers to
related methods you can get through over
epsilon but all of this depends on Rho
and as you have no mention Rho is the
largest entry inside the matrix so these
algorithms are not are not polynomial
you know this row is that the actual
number but not the description so it
could be exponentially large in the
description of the trap even more water
angling you know maybe there is only one
entry which is huge and your if you are
going to steal us to evidence there is
no running time because there is one
entry that's very much
so
[Music]
so what's the there is this since there
is no I non-negative linear program so
interesting is that there are this width
independent algorithms and the kind of
the 2d first weight independent
algorithm was given by lubing Nixon in
1993 and they essentially started with
some continuous-time interpretation they
came up with a way of solving this pure
packing and cover angle piece in this
number of iterations either or tilde
Heights log factors so some poly log
over epsilon to the fourth and the
running time which is an over action to
the fourth where n is the sparsity of
your constraint matrix is only nonzero
number of non-zeros in the constraint
matrix so this is great because there is
no row here doesn't matter how big how
small this this constraint at there is
something that allows us to really just
depend on a number of nonzero meters
these are luminescent is only for pure
there are algorithms to achieve this
kind of a mean time for a mix and
packaging they were discovered after
Ruby and listen
the original minimus I believe it's only
for Purim there's a lot of work on this
but I know that it mixed the list
packing and covering you can do with one
over epsilon cube it's the best known
algorithm that is correct yes I am a
division right it's a very good point so
in all of this talk and I'm assuming
that our problem is listen to me
explicitly okay so I see this whole
matrix the beauty of some of these more
general techniques like middle descent
is this that this also work this one in
particular and this one they work for
implicitly defined linear programs or
even online and your programs in which I
don't see all the constraints but I can
find one constraint is violated or I
have an Oracle that gives me a new
constraint that I've iteration you still
get this kind of running times in order
to get a Rho over epsilon you need this
explicit property but for the purpose of
this talk I want to keep it very simple
so just thing in this framework in which
we see the whole constraint matrix there
are very interesting cases which are
mentioned in the open problems where we
want to do implicit ribbon in your
project so in some sense these methods
are more powerful because they extend to
more online settings but you know even
if you really go look at the best force
all the methods we know this kind of you
know I think these row dependence is
inescapable I think there are a few
papers that manage to turn this row into
an N but so you will get quadratic
running time nothing is the algorithm by
do be nice and will be the first
algorithm they gave with independent
need a linear time which is what people
in practice really want you I mean if
you ask somebody what she works with
this the first requirement is it has to
be need a linear time because n is huge
with independent because the numbers
inside these problems vary a lot and the
other thing is just out that is absent
to the fourth is actually pretty poor
so this algorithm did not really get too
much traction in practice at least as
far as I understand people have been
deception to the forest is so poor and
it's actually is actually appears in the
empirical evaluations that people would
rather use the interior point methods so
we'll see that in recent work a bunch of
people including myself have improved
the largely the state of this dependence
what he's talking about is about okay so
when man gave his introduction I kinda
freaked out because I had no plot so in
the last minute I added a few parts
these are not the most polished so just
copied some paper but I think they they
give you an idea so this is for the part
of the kind of algorithms so loopy and
nice and gave a log and log squared n
over epsilon action to the fourth
iteration and if you years ago ago with
say one Alan show we improve this to
epsilon cube and I want to show you
something that's going to be useful
later understanding of this running time
number of iteration changes as you vary
epsilon so something that we will see is
that these algorithms work by taking the
original known a smooth problem and
smoothing it so a different choice of
epsilon which are also the correspond to
different choices of parameters in the
algorithms they need two different
smooth things of the original LP and so
you see that each choice of epsilon here
kind of becomes flat the objective LP
value becomes flat at a certain point
that's really the phenomenon that the
the iterative solver has really solved
optimally essentially that smoothing of
the problem so this is the actual value
this is the actual value of optimum and
these are different values achieved by
different choices of epsilon they all
become flat before they hit this because
all these internal syllables I'm not
actually solving the original LP but
you're solving a smoothing as most
version of it which has a slightly lower
objective
there's a typical phenomenon that you
will see for the solvers this is a more
useful graph it's a comparison with
other methods for similar choices of
smooth things and so our algorithm so
this is our old algorithm was it's kind
of superior to all of them and actually
this is a kind of a mild example this is
a very small instance is like 800 known
and is like 800 and if you take these
two much larger distances this is even
more dramatic so this is kind of my
token plot and now I want to kind of
just be a bit more abstract and I want
to talk about so why is even with
independents possible like what's what's
enabling is the existence of this faster
algorithm so first I think I'm gonna
start by going on the board and talking
for a second just as a review of like
how would you go about solving a
genetical T and then we will we will see
our within the same framework we can
make some improvements and solve one of
these non-negative linear programs
instead in a faster time
how much how long is this stuff I could
go back thank you little details I
forget to check sometimes visually okay
so look at approximately solving a
linear program using first order methods
okay so suppose we are just trying to
solve ax less or equal to B so really
you know we are trying to come up with
an approximate solver so in some sense
you can think about it as trying to
minimize some epsilon where ax minus B
is less than epsilon times 1 so you
think about it as you want to minimize
the maximum violation
so yeah I should say I'm working with
the feasibility problem so you can
reduce 4lp and in general you can reduce
the optimization optimizing a program to
checking whether the program is feasible
using binary search so let's just worry
about this also because the notation
will be already complex enough without
having another objective function
floating around so that's what you're
trying to do and it's not hard to come
up with a saddle point formulation of
this wanna minimize overall X exactly
the quantity and another way of writing
this maximum violation is really by
taking Y over the simplex thinking about
Y transpose ax minus P this just picks
out to the maximum element of ax minus B
which happens to be the maximum
violation okay so now we really think
about this function here is the function
we are trying to optimize which is nice
comebacks known as most function
most because it's a it's a max of a
linear function so the main trick which
I'm sure many of you are familiar with
but is this idea of a smoothing
regularization idea is that this problem
is non smooth let's change it a tiny bit
and in the process let's make it smooth
and the way that's done in this setting
when you're working over the simplex is
simply by adding an entropy term any
questions on this
so now you're trying really to maximize
not only minimize not all in the maximum
element but some trade-off or maximum
element and entropy over why
and this ETA is a is a positive is a
non-negative parameter result is that
you get this nice function denies now
you want to minimize so this year is the
complex conjugate or something so this
function I can actually be written as
ETA
we call this the softmax parameter ETA
of the vector ax - me so so many of you
probably seen this function this it's a
smooth version of the maximum of the
entries in this vector it's it's a good
approximation to to the original if you
can actually show that the max of a X
minus B is less than the softmax X minus
B which is less than the max plus ETA
log on this log and comes from the
maximum value of the entropy so it's a
nice function where eta is Mark it's
very near to Max but it has this benefit
that it is moved
softmax is one Overeaters motion with
respect to the L infinity no this is a
standard thing in your shield
organization this function is strongly
convex to respect to L 1 and so this is
more to respect to L infinity
[Music]
it is a kind of how you would set up
from the point of view of smoothing this
[Music]
the solution of a general linear program
once every smooth function you can apply
a kind of your your favorite your
favorite first under method for solving
for smooth optimization okay so now we
have the smooth function using as most
optimization server so this could be it
could be gradient descent mirror descent
vision descent and you will get suffer
for gradient descent and Miller descent
you'll get results that look like the
smoothness times log n times some notion
of diameter over m squared and for AGD
you get the square root of the notice
that I just wrote moistness here like
hell there is a catch which is you know
when I go through this reduction the the
smoothness of
softmax is one of Rita but my variables
are not a X minus B my variables are X
so the actual smoothness of for theta of
X as a function of X
is one over Rita and then you need to
multiply you're looking really at the
essence we really need to multiply by
the norm of a squared usually the way
that this is done is people look at the
1 to infinity normal this is again the
largest entropy
it's gonna be your bad yo and so if you
want your error to be epsilon you would
set leader to be absent of a log n log N
actually so I cheated a bit but
essentially this is the kind of
smoothness you get and if you do things
right here you'll just get the norm of a
square and the normal fee
yeah just the idea that they want to
show you is that we have this nice soft
max regularization but because our
variables are X and not a X we pay this
extra cost the editor of the square of
this normal failure there are just entry
fee and that shows up in all our bounds
so then the idea is you know what you
really want to be able to do is if some
senses do is apply one or desire isthmus
in the ax space really this is just for
generic linear programs so this should
be a yeah I made a mistake the way I
wrote it before so this is correct
I didn't mean to write L this is the
correct rush so the idea no the kind of
way I want to present with independence
to you is that we are going to be able
to run one of these algorithms while
really living in this ax pace instead of
reading in this ax space and then our
smoothness is really going to be log n
over epsilon instead of this
any questions about about this so in
some sense if you actually look inside
these algorithms there are multiple
places in which you can strengthen this
disagreement there is a strengthening
and order smoothing that you're gonna
need which is pretty simple but cute
and then the main interesting thing for
me is that there is a strengthening of
the way you can do gradient descent
which makes it look more like you're
working in this area space rather than
in this egg space
you know what I can go on the board okay
let me so I have 15 minutes let me
quickly tell you tell you about these
two stranglings this one is actually
dual to this one so it's less
interesting so first a difference is mu
thing and this is kind of not strictly
necessary but it makes things much
easier to work with and it has
algorithmic consequences so you wanted
to show it to you so I'm going to start
with you know this formulation here now
I'm gonna do something slightly
different which is and now already
tamarin thing now is like say for
packing a piece so rather than doing
that so I'm gonna do I'm gonna think
about minimizing -1 transpose X such
that px is less than 1 because I like
convex functions
and I think about minimizing and then
I'm gonna have maximum over why okay so
this is kind of an equivalent formula is
my saddle point formulation same idea is
there but now rather than bounding on
the simplex I'm making this kind of a
penalty function my this is like an
indicator when P X is larger than one
this guy blows to infinity in the same
program and now rather than using the
usual entropy I use this organizer which
is the generalized entropy so and it's
the entropy but extended to the whole
positive rtant thank you
I
[Music]
this usually does not work for genetical
piece but it gives nice bounce for
packing and covering so the using the
non-negativity we get both a
regularization error let me first write
the this move function there's nothing
that we get it's a function that you'll
see a lot if you look at any of these
packing and covering papers you'll
always see this function popping up
this is the closed form of these max
this is you can really think about as a
penalty term it's a kind of a harsher
penalty that in that case because there
is no log in front you just an
exponential and we have some nice bounce
with the regularization error so here we
used to get an additive error it turns
out that in general this recognizer is
not good for genetical piece because you
can get a very big error but for non-
lp's you get nice bounce you get that
let me write it in terms of up you get
the the the opt of the LP is within log
and is within a multiplicative factor
the the mean is at me and i should say -
after because but after opt of that'll
be is within a multiplicative factor
yeah I never got this music thank you
okay so this is one this depends on the
negativity so the fact that you can use
in smoothing this different smoothing
depends on adding packing and covered
angle peace and let me tell you why this
mu thing is nice so in this case during
your program you would have to take
gradients of this and the gradient of
this function so let's call it G G of X
is this exponential weights that you
might have seen so the gradient at I
looks like a J I e to the ax minus B
we have seen so this is what the
gradient of the softmax looks like if
you want to do a distributed algorithm
you start having trouble because each of
your variables needs to know about the
normalized sum of all this weight this
more thing is not very good for
distributed algorithms and while if you
use this mu thing the gradient as mu is
there is no normalization now because
there is no log and it's just minus V so
this is very important if you wanna get
distributed algorithms it makes life
much simpler and then I should also
mention that there are other regular
risers that only work in this
non-negative linear program setting that
are even nicer you cannot see Lena about
it if if you are interested so that's it
the idea for this more thing different
kind of most thing you can do for
non-negative L piece now let me give you
a quick idea of why you can do something
different for gradient descent which I
think it's kind of very well it's a
crucial point in understanding why we
can dependence is possible
try to be fast because I also want to
tell you about the open problems
okay so I want you to keep in mind this
F new function actually you can take mu
to be epsilon over log n but what do you
do when you do gradient descent you're
kind of you're looking at the Taylor
approximation of the function around
your point because the function is moved
you have some upper bound to it and then
you can try to move you move to the
point which minimizes your upper bound
that is been designed for smooth
functions so let's do the same here
well let's be a bit more careful let's
unity to this function f new what does a
Taylor expansion of X mu suppose I am at
some point X and I add some Delta so
this could be a vector this is gonna be
the gradient of F mu which have already
written there and then what I care about
is this
Sen term the second-order term usually
when you use mootness you would just
write you know something depending on
the norm instead you're going to be more
careful we can actually estimate the
actual action of our problem and there
is a simple argument here this says that
as long as ETA times a times Delta is
less than 1 over Epsilon
as long as you live within this ball it
is kind of the ball in which - and
doesn't change too much this is like it
is like 1 over mu
remember that this gradient here by what
I wrote before was a transpose Y ax
minus 1 well these are these exponential
weights gotta mention it here this
gradient here has these exponential
weights
I call this each of these weight Y acts
of I he really tells me you know it's a
measure of our via by related is the I
constraint is this is a gradient and the
action looks like this the diagonal of Y
a ok so now I can at least give you some
intuition of why you would expect to be
able to do something better than
gradient descent ok so when is hmm just
everywhere thank you III really not to
do this like it she follows me around
okay
so what's happening is so when if we
then designed to bed waiting the scent
is bad when your function is not very
smooth okay so in some sense this blue
curve is a large curvature and you
cannot make big steps so you think of
that as that you know but smoothness in
some sense means that this quantity is
large this particular direction Delta
you're moving in and this quantity is
large so you cannot really so you're
first to make a small step okay but what
happens because of non-negative is no
negativity of a is that whenever this
quantity is large you can actually show
that a transpose Y X must also be large
that happens because all these numbers
here are non-negative so there are no
cancellations inside this product that
means that the only way in which this
can be loud
really if his eight transpose Wieck is
large but a transpose Y is related to
the gradient so this is saying that the
function is non smooth so it curves very
quickly
only when the gradient is steep that
means that even in those cases you can
make a certain improvement that in
general is not possible so in general
you know smoothness may be present even
when the function is kind of very flat
so this basic idea posted a lot to kind
of work around it because this is good
but it doesn't give you much unless you
combine it you know you'd really have to
use it in a smart way gives all these
with independent algorithms in the last
minute I hope I gave you some intuition
so part of the the goal of our papers
was really to get to this kind of more
optimization friendly view of with
independence because the original papers
are written from a more purely
algorithmic standpoint without the
consideration of relation to other
optimization classes there are some
coolest tensions in particular to SDPs
so surprisingly with a lot of work on
integrals of Exponential's you can kind
of get the same result for packing s the
piece and for and for stuff for some
implicit recipes ok open problems is
something so there was the photon
problems in this idea and lots of things
I really don't understand yet so in
order of increasing vagueness very
concrete problems we still have some
mismatch in and some open questions
about running times so the biggest open
question to me is can you get a parallel
so over the transom one over excellent
this is a fine so a practical very
important question right now the best is
one of option squared and if we could
write to one over
parallel or disability server these
would have practical implications our
results for miss covering mixed packing
covering are worse than the ones for
pure packing and covering so fix that
understand better this theory of
difference mu things for these
non-negative linear programs so some
part of me thinking about construct you
know can add that logger bounce relevant
rubber bounds for these non-negative
linear programs from reductions from
genetical piece that we mentioned so
using these same ideas for implicit
packing and covering and I think
Chandrashekar we had some results on
this in my first talk in the bootcamp I
talked about the continuous-time
analogue a first-order method and it is
discretization viewpoint the kind of was
useful in understanding how you could
very you could modify the algorithm I
don't have any discretization
understanding of these guys right and
then the cool thing is what happens in
all these algorithms is that your Delta
because you want to respect this you
want to pick a delta that has to respect
this condition the game you tend to play
is that you keep your ax feasible and
you really think of your Delta as some
kind of diagonal scaling of X so you
know in some sense what you know at time
T is that this direction the X Direction
is good if your ax is feasible so lots
of these algorithms are based on
multiplicative updates so you take your
X each X and you multiply my small
constant and there is a kind of there is
a way of thinking about this in some
sense the right variables shouldn't be X
Y should be into the Y this Act should
be a financial there is an open question
of whether there is a way of
reformulating all of these using these
exponential change of variable and then
interior points no can you use these
ideas for interior interior point
methods for these guys
[Applause]
[Music]
in the fact that you're using this
multiplicative updates well first in the
fact that you can tolerate the new to be
[Music]
epsilon over log n which is what you
would get if you if you were working the
range of a and then the fact that your
your updates are you know multiplicative
in X because you're only trying to
maintain this property we were we
respect of how much you're moving in the
range of a really time to have moves
make moves that don't change your slacks
or your violations too much so in the
sense they give you a bounded movement
in the range of a while walking while
moving in the right directions so now
these appears to be easier for these
negative apiece
Yeah right
so the diameter here the there is a
trick in some sense where the diameter
you can read somehow related I amateur
to opt so it kind of gets built into
this multiplicative approximation
[Applause]